derrière vous avez une télé qui est
dingue pour le gaming avec 240 Hertz 240
images par seconde alors là on se parle
d'un monstre on est sur du 98 pouces
résolution 4K alors le 241 vous servira
absolument pas pour venir regarder des
films et des séries non ça sert à rien
mais imaginez vous voulez jouer à des
jeux avec une très belle expérience très
belle fluidité et bien là vous avez un
affichage avec 240 images par seconde
c'est juste démentiel donc on voit que
même si ça c'est que entre auto on monte
les technologies c'est chez TCL au CES
pour autant ça pourra arriver plus tard
dans quelques années peut-être sur des
télégrands publics 240 images par
seconde c'est un truc de fou d'ailleurs
dites-moi si vous êtes gamer gameuse si
ça pourrait vous intéresser vous le
marquer dans les commentaires